oh say can you see by the dawn's take it
down take it down take down not just
about that flag it's about the
underpinning of white supremacy and
racism and white privilege in this
country
that our flag was to you we want to make
this about history yes please let's make
it about history let's make it about
heritage but let's make it about
everyone's history objectively let's
make it about everyone's heritage
objectively I know what a leg stands for
it's bigotry white supremacy I actually
have Confederate ancestry and I'm very
familiar with civil war and what was
fought for but yet the flag should
definitely come down we've been fighting
the Civil War 150 years here in South
Carolina and it's time to get it over
No
everyone's talking about taking down the
Confederates laughing with the events of
Charleston the people who believe in